it's great to welcome to the program
today barry meyer who is the former
pulitzer prize-winning new york times
reporter and author of the book spooked
the secret rise of private spies uh
barry it's so great to have you on today
thanks david thanks so much for inviting
me on so to start with when we talk
about private spies
we're not talking about a private
investigator
because you suspect your spouse might be
cheating on you
we're really talking here about high
level uh intelligence work that often
relates to
foreign policy domestic policy etc give
us like an
overview of this industry and kind of
how it developed
sure uh it really got its start back in
the
late 1970s with a gentleman by the name
of
jules kroll who created a company called
curl associates and at that time the
public image
of the of you know the private
investigator was as you mentioned
you know the guy in a raincoat who like
hangs around motels trying to catch uh
cheating spouses uh crow realized that
there was a huge marketplace
for investigative services particularly
from corporations because this was a
period of time
where there were a lot of corporate
takeovers and shareholder battles
so he formed what was essentially
the investigative equivalent of a law
firm you know these guys dressed well
they looked good he hired not only
ex-fbi agents and former prosecutors
but really smart college graduates who
were
interested in investigations and
uh thus began
this industry that describes itself as
you know corporate investigators
or or corporate intelligence but
basically they are
skilled investigators who are hired by
law firms hollywood moguls
uh political parties you name it to go
out
and dig up information and often dirt
on their clients adversaries and
this can include i mean uh i'm reading
lawrence wright's going clear right now
the church of scientology employs uh
individuals like this uh
regularly we could talk about the
so-called
trump dossier and whether that would fit
the bill is the type of product that
that would kind of be produced by this
what are some of the maybe less
obvious uh functions of such private
spies
yeah so it could be anything from you
know what we think of as
legitimate uh use of investigators uh
you know finding missing people it could
be
digging up material for lawsuits
locating witnesses
for lawsuits but the range is huge
as you mentioned groups like scientology
which are under public scrutiny
will hire investigators to dig up
information or even try to
intimidate their adversaries uh or
critics i mean when i was
first working for the time back when i
was working for the times investigating
purdue pharma
they hired kroll to investigate people
who were suing the company and also
looked at me
not long ago when patrick rayden keith
was writing his book about sack
the sacklers he found investigators
sitting outside
his house then you had cases where
uh hollywood has you know made
use of private investigators all the
time to intimidate people there was a
famous case of anthony pelicano
who uh broke into the car of a los
angeles times reporter
who was looking into him so i mean the
gamut
is huge what kind of unites
uh this industry i would say
is the willingness of these individuals
these
investigators private spies whatever you
want to call them
to use any means necessary
to gather information about their
targets so
that and that gets me to maybe you know
we'll talk about
in a moment maybe some ways in in which
there's sort of a
upside here to private spies but it
seems one of the concerns would be
there might be things corporations want
done or governments want done
or whoever that they
would be worried about being caught
doing and the private investigator
provides at least plausible deniability
is that in fact the case is that what
exactly you know it's you know basically
it's private investigators have been
described as the gloves
that lawyers put on when they don't want
to get their hands dirty
and so that's that's the concept here i
mean they
will undertake uh
things that you know lawyers will claim
they never ordered and
are shocked to learn when it comes out
they they in fact signed off on it
perfect example being david boyce's firm
as you know david boyes is probably one
of the best-known lawyers
in the united states he's most famous
for uh the
gore bush recount working for the
democratic party in that case
also for bringing the litigation in the
supreme court that
led to the upholding of same-sex
marriage you know a
good guy uh in the view in the eyes of
most people
in fact uh his law firm uh signed off
on a contract that called for this
uh you know law this israeli
private uh spying firm black cube
who uses kind of very despicable types
of tactics
to one uh spy
on women who were
bringing claims of sexual assault
against harvey weinstein and also spy on
reporters for the new yorker
and the new york times who were
investigating uh harvey weinstein's uh
sexual uh assault allegations
yeah if people are interested in that
ronan farrow's uh
recent book the title of the book
escapes me
but it's by ronan farrow and it's about
the harvey weinstein story
outlines outlines that that quite a bit
um
catch and kill yes exactly now to sort
of i don't even know if this is playing
devil's advocate but to sort of see it
from the other side
there are definitely circumstances we
could imagine where
the power of a government the american
government for example
could be brought down against someone uh
for political reasons
or for reasons that you me or anybody
might say are
are not on the up and up um is there a
case to be made that
the ability to hire so-called private
spy
to try to uh match at least in some
small way
the government's ability to bring
political charges and
use their investigative power against an
individual or a corporation could be a
good thing i mean i'm thinking out loud
here
yes i mean you know let me give you a
perfect example because there's a
lawsuit playing out right now
uh and the parties of the lawsuit
neither of them are particularly
attractive they're not good guys
in in carmen common parlance
but through a uh
just a bizarre set of circumstances the
defendant in the case
became aware that his emails had been
hacked
and that his emails had been hacked
uh and dumped on the internet on this
sort of obscure
law uh website where lawyers for his
adversary suddenly
discovered them and then used them in
litigation against him
right well after this case was decided
it was so uh it was subsequently
uncovered
by a group of internet activists
what the likely source of the hacked
material was who had done the hacking
and this individual then went out and
retained his own private investigator
to dig into this and is now constructing
a case
to expose the hacking that went on
against him
and so you know there are many
situations where the use of a private
investigator private spy
to defend yourself to go and uncover
wrongdoing that has been taken place
against
you be by a government or by an
individual actor private
actor is more than justified if we
want to think about the way that uh
journalists
as well as um the media and
consumers of media should think about
information that comes from
private spies i mean there's sort of
protocol for
how do you handle um a politician when
you're talking to them for a story you
might be writing
how do you deal with an anonymous source
how do you deal with a sort of civilian
non-public person in order to provide
them certain
protections in terms of both the
individuals and the information that
comes from them
how should journalist reporters and
interviewers be be thinking about
what comes from private spies
well i think this is you know this is a
real motivation for me when i wrote the
book
and it was uh there was a certain
epiphany for me
when i wrote the book because i deal a
lot with the
the steele dossier you know the the
opposition research that was done
against donald steele
by this private investigative firm that
hired
an ex mi6 agent against donald trump
just to be clear just so the audience
you met you you
don't you said donald steele you met
donald trump donald trump right
and christopher steele this mi6 agent
was hired
to basically gather dirt on donald trump
in russia
now when this was being shot
to media organizations it was implicit
when it was being shown around by an
investigative firm
in dc that was in fact formed by two
former
wall street journal reporters that they
couldn't identify the involvement of
this firm
fusion gps or christopher steele in the
gathering of this
information had to come from you know
sort of
you know appear out of the blue it was
like you know immaculate conception
and uh when buzzfeed published
this information on the web and it was
embraced by
particularly you know opponents of
donald trump
and sort of became the focus of
political and cultural and media
conversation
for three years uh it didn't come out
until late in the game that in fact this
was a product
of these private operatives right we put
it together and no one even knew
what sources they were drawing upon and
so you know
the the lesson i try to draw in the book
and the sort of
issue that comes out in the book is that
you know
we as journalists and i consider myself
one
um is that we really have to be more
transparent with our audience with our
readers our viewers our listeners about
where this information
is coming from why should we give people
who are paid
to gather what's effectively dirt and
use
our stories our articles
our broadcast as the means to
disseminate that information to the
public
why should we treat them like
whistleblowers why should we give them
complete
anonymity because it's not fair to the
public
the public is being misled and
you know this dance has gone on this
symbiotic relationship that
has gone on between journalists and
private spies for decades
but if there is one lesson we should
take away
from the whole you know steel trump
dossier
incident is that we really do need to be
more transparent
they need to be identified as sources
whereas the fbi might be a source for
something about an investigation we
would identify where these influences
like
from a government source yeah you know
you need to
when people have a vested interest in
getting out
information you don't have to say it's
coming from fusion's ups you don't have
to say
per se is coming from christopher steele
but you damn well sure saying
that it was put together by individuals
who had
an axe to grind or were being paid to
plant this information
this was a paid research project by
opponents of donald trump
absolutely yes absolutely by the
democratic national committee
and the money was like laundered through
lawyers for the democratic
national committee and once journalists
became aware
that fusion gps and
christopher steele were involved in it
then they had a duty to go a step
further and to scrutinize those people
right to scrutinize that firm to
scrutinize christopher steele
and say what do we know about these
people who have their clients been in
the past
and how does that influence our
assessment or analysis of how
accurate the claims in the dossier are
in the very limited time we have left is
your sense that
the the dossier is sort of a mixed bag
in the sense that
uh i mean i'll just leave it there like
for example i spoke to michael cohen
last week and he said the thing about
him going to prague
he's really never been to prague it
wasn't like uh well he was in the
airport but he didn't clear customs and
so technically it was
like he just he doesn't know where that
came from but
there were other things in there that
either by coincidence or
or because they were better researched
were true
yeah there's there's no doubt that the
russian government uh
tried to influence the 2016 election
there is no doubt that donald trump
and his allies his son embraced
uh efforts by russia to influence the
election i mean
russia are you listening right i mean
wasn't that his big
uh campaign uh rap
so yeah i mean there was
that russia was trying to influence
but that wasn't you that finding or that
that
assertion was not unique to the steele
dossier you know
it wasn't he was not the only person
that became aware of that
what is troubling is that the specific
allegations
in the steele dossier one that that
michael cohen
went to prague when in fact if michael
cohen had a lot
michael cohen lied about a lot of things
and he got rung up for lying
yeah but if and he would have gotten
rough up rung up for lying about that
and he didn't so he wasn't in prague for
that meeting
uh that that carter page another trump
uh ally was offered like this huge stake
in a russian
um uh energy company no evidence that
that occurred and the most infamous of
all
p-tape which uh has yet to emerge so
there is
there is a lot and there's a lot in the
dossier which either
has um not proven to be true
or been proven not to be true
we've been speaking with barry meyer
author of the book
spooked the secret rise of private spies
uh barry such a pleasure having you on i
really appreciate your time
and thank you david i really appreciate
your having me on today